that's what it's not it doesn't bug me
when somebody's just they have you know
the slender neck but when they go
through so much trouble to look like an
alpha male right but they have that
little chicken neck right and then
they're posing like there that's gotta
be my issue with you like as a woman
like the way you interact with men as a
world-champion muy tarde woman yeah you
figured that out you have to have a hard
time with the men I do
I bet you do I do yeah cuz you need to
get a real one like a real real I just
selling way it's gonna work doesn't know
yeah imagine it's hard out there for a
pimp it is right so I had his a great
boyfriend but we went out of country we
fought on the same card he fought the
day before me I fought the next day
during the fight he almost gets knocked
out as the sky is mauling him he goes
like this what do you think I was
thinking um not good dogs the boyfriend
the boyfriend the boyfriend was like
yeah you didn't like it [ __ ] now to turn
you off oh my god so much whoa I was
like dude you're getting [ __ ] up and
you drop you as you're falling to the
canvas you Neal's still need to go [ __ ]
you so the way is did he beaten was
[ __ ] with you
was it just that he was getting beaten
yeah I don't care if it wasn't yeah like
you gotta [ __ ] like take that [ __ ]
okay yeah like you know like a champ or
like a like a fighter right yeah you
can't be like wow yeah great first way
feels great maybe sometimes it's like
that's the problem it's that the balance
the ones who are not gonna be great
boyfriends are the ones that are going
to turn you on they're ruthless yeah
yeah I was like I can balance that [ __ ]
I gotta be ruthless yeah
like gentle mmm not well I mean I'm sure
some can sweet my kale chips it's great
yeah I get it I don't get it
some people can yeah yeah but I mean I
think your requirements particularly as
a fighter they're gonna be
extraordinarily high as a world champion
fighter yeah yeah yeah I said I was
better off dating a guy who's like a
Navy SEAL or something who can't fight
Oh or maybe a fight but he's not a
fighter
yeah doesn't yeah he knows how to fight
he's a killer he's a killer not a
fighter it's not in there mmm-hmm fight
it maybe like you could relate more yeah
yeah person I'll try it out and I'll let
you know well I think that I've noticed
this I mean except for the ones that are
lesbians I was look at women who are
fighters mm-hmm like they're limited in
their dating pool yeah because girls who
are fighters they don't want to date
someone who can't fight the last thing a
girl wants who's like a professional
fighter or if somebody was really smart
you know yeah but even the guys really
smart because because then they like as
long as they a Smee somewhere they have
to be really [ __ ] you're like no you can
say that you trying to find a nice man
you like me back in compromise no you
need a killer no it would bother me
about that was like you're a fighter but
you're not being a fighter right I'm
just like not savage enough oh well
you're worried that if the [ __ ] hits the
fan that's what every woman is worried
if the [ __ ] hits the fan how do you
react how do you react and you don't
really know until you see someone react
when the [ __ ] hits the fan and when you
see the [ __ ] hitting the fan you see
them going to Ikes like [ __ ] I can't
count on you I think he would have been
better outside of the fighting situation
outside if the [ __ ] hit the fan oh so it
so for me it was definitely like writers
ego like nah dude you need to have more
pride than that
well how you do anything is how you do
everything okay all right maybe yeah
especially under duress I mean pianist
Jake's people panic people
learn from those mistakes I mean there
are people that fold in fights that come
back way stronger and will never fold
because they folded before they felt it
because mistake you know you you you
make a split-second decision in the
middle of a fight and you know something
something inside you you you you it
exposes weakness that maybe you weren't
prepared for the world to see and then
when you feel the pain of that weakness
you make a vow that you're never gonna
experience that again that's entirely
possible
I feel like mental strength is not I
don't think you to have it you don't
have it I don't buy that [ __ ] I think
you can develop it I think you can build
it and I think mental toughness and just
the ability to persevere is something
that you can cultivate I really believe
that absolutely absolutely all shying
away and feel you going hey [ __ ]
you know when you're getting hit don't
don't do any of this [ __ ] maybe needs to
hear that so then when it's happening
they go [ __ ] that I'm not doing this
anymore
take a deep and step to the side or clan
Church it's just like go out like a
warrior
yeah yeah or figure your way a better
better response to the situation then
again sometimes you get clipped in your
neuromuscular system just goes up and
everything is just off it's just you're
not responding right because your your
systems getting shut it was more like I
got away from me that's not good yeah I
don't like that